congress continues to try to raise the
debt ceiling they can't stop they
literally spend so much money they spend
like a drunken sailor they cannot stop
spending money every time they go to
spend more and more money they
eventually come up against the debt
ceiling back in october we had this same
problem you had a bunch of people saying
the us government's gonna go bankrupt we
can't default on our debt this is the
doomsday scenario we must lift the debt
ceiling and of course as always if
you're watching this show we told you
don't worry about it the us government
is not going to default this is all a
charade it's all a game and of course at
the 11th hour what did they do they went
ahead and they made the change and when
they made that change they increased the
debt ceiling by 480 billion dollars but
because they only did 480 billion
dollars that means that we went from
october doomsday scenario to
today in december then again doomsday
scenario we're going to run out of money
we're going to default oh no there's bad
stuff in december how the hell is it
that the government constantly gets to
the point where they think they're going
to run out of money every couple of
months this is absurd it's because we
have undisciplined monetary and fiscal
policy we have a entire political regime
that believes spending other people's
money
is their job and so ultimately what
we're facing now is an increase of up to
two trillion dollars we just did 480
billion now they're talking about a two
trillion dollar increase to the debt
ceiling the way that this is going to
work is that the house just passed a
procedural bill earlier this week that
bill now proceeds to the senate at least
10 republicans will have to join the
democrats and all the democrats have to
vote along with those 10 republicans to
move this procedure forward from there
the senate will then vote to raise the
debt ceiling with passage obtainable by
a simple majority vote and the senate is
expected to vote on the bill today both
chambers of congress congress would then
vote on the terms of the debt limit
itself the more that we
go forward the more we're gonna see
nonsense like this
what would be a wild idea
is rather than continue to increase the
debt ceiling why don't we start with
spending less money than we make
that would be a crazy idea the us
government since 2011 every single year
has taken in more federal tax income
2012 was more than 2011 2013 was more
than 2012 all the way up until 2021 the
government's getting more revenue but at
the same time they're making more money
the government is also spending at a
greater deficit every single year which
means that the deficit they spent more
than what they actually made in 2011 but
in 2012 the gap was bigger 2013 it was
bigger than that all the way up until
now so no matter how much money the
federal government takes in they
continue to spend even more of it it is
like a business that says hey i made x
dollars to start and i lost money last
year this year i made more money but i
lost even more dollars and that is why
we continue to push up against this debt
ceiling
we need reasonable people we need
rational people we need people who
understand a budget because ultimately
you cannot do this forever you cannot
continue to spend more than you make so
this government and this economy does
not have an income problem they take
plenty of money and they continue to
increase the tax burden on americans
but they continue to spend at an even
greater pace and so we have a spending
problem not an income problem two
trillion dollar increase of the debt
limit
comical at this point yeah i mean janet
yellen is screaming that uh the everyone
needs to pay their bills the u.s needs
to pay their bills and then we just go
raise the debt limit to go pay those
bills so like i don't understand how
that really works it's supposed to cost
zero dollars remember the program is
going to cost zero dollars yeah
like many other people have said they
got you concentrated on the actual cost
of the program to uh to dive away from
the idea that we should do it at all of
course
this is all nonsense john what do you
think
uh printing more money is terrible for
the inflation that's already been
persistent with 6.2 percent cpi i think
the new cpi numbers come out on friday
so we'll see where that lands but look
defaulting on our debt obligations is
probably worse right than just
raising the inflation rate so
i have a feeling this bill will probably
get passed
um they really need to stop spending
money
the other piece of this that uh
i think people forget about is like
whether they actually create new money
they borrow money whatever it is right
they're continuously just spending and
spending and spending and i think that
there's two situations that are
absolutely absurd in society right now
the first is this idea that if we spend
more money we'll actually uh decrease
inflation absurd
literally the most absurd thing ever the
second thing is that they have people
convinced that the government is
actually going to default
right like they're they literally are
yelling and screaming saying that the
government's going to default
and it's just you get to this point of
like look everyone just calm down we
understand you guys are going to
continue to do this why increase it by 2
trillion let's just go ahead and
increase it by 20 trillion
let's just leap ahead so we don't have
to do this every three months
because if you look at this
in october 480 billion if they were to
do two trillion now what's that get us
maybe the whole year next year no
because it's like february
yeah it depends right depends on what
they're spending on and so you just get
in this world where you're just like
look this stuff is all nonsense uh and
you can easily see how people get caught
up in like all of the minutia about it
but if you go to washington dc and you
walk around there these people literally
think that they're important right they
literally think that this stuff is like
the end of the world and the rest of
america is sitting there saying like you
guys are fools
it's also seven days before we
supposedly default on our obligations
right so why push it when if we
did basically an extension from october
to now why is it till now that it's just
getting to the house and says well
because actually we're not going to make
the decision today seven days we're
going to wait till midnight the night
before like it's like it's like remember
when we were all in high school and
they're like your homework's due on
tuesday and you're like cool yeah i'll
do i'll do it monday night i'll do it
and then monday night comes like i'll do
it tomorrow morning and then you get to
the hallway and you're like oh [ __ ] and
you pull out the worksheet and you're
like doing it on like a locker real
quick like that's the us government the
funniest one to me is the filibuster
i love when they do the philippines
all sides of the aisle i'm like yo y'all
are really going to stand up there for
12 hours and talk like legends yeah i
mean it's legendary but come on like
there's gotta be what's the longest
filibuster anyone's ever done we should
we should try to figure it out should we
do a filibuster ourselves and see if we
could out filibuster a filibuster let's
see and see if like if it's 12 hours i
mean we could easily sit here and just
talk or uh read things for 13 hours that
wouldn't be hard 24 hours 24 hours
no way
24-hour filibusters pretty crazy do you
get to go get delusional by the end of
the
day
democrats wait is this true there might
be multiple people who can also
participate in the filibuster it may not
be a one a one person thing like you may
be able to pass the baton you know yeah
you could pass the baton because they're
saying uh okay all right so there's it
looks like there's a dog yeah you gotta
get a little relay race you know coming
up
there's two it looks like uh the longest
filibuster was u.s senator strom thorman
thurman from south carolina spoke for 24
hours and 18 minutes straight like one
person yeah
legend which is like rand paul people
are saying he did 24 hours there's a
bunch of other ones uh there was a
couple people who did 22 hours 18 16.
but then there's a claim here it's it's
one of those fact checking websites i
don't know if it's true yeah but we got
to fact check the fact that yeah we got
to fact check the factors but they're
saying democrats held the senate
filibuster and uh to prevent the passing
of the 1964 civil rights act for 75 days
straight yeah so people are saying that
is the longest one ever the longest one
but the filibuster what it obviously
there's something but that's
multitasking
wait the democrats tried to uh block the
civil rights act
let's see
i ain't going down that rabbit hole but
y'all can take it from that whatever you
want that sounds like a piece of history
that might have gotten uh looked over uh
all right
when we think about uh the filibuster by
the way if you were to do a filibuster
would you go uh off the cuff and just
talk or would you read something like
would you go and big i'm gonna read the
dictionary if you're what are you going
in with a mindset like i got a 24-hour
filibuster coming up oh yeah yeah yeah
literally
walk in and they're like yo i'm gonna go
for as long as i can like you're gonna
you're gonna carry me out on a stretcher
just ignorant at that point i mean
that's the point that's why it's like
this is so dumb y'all are just gonna go
up there and waste my time yeah but you
guys are gonna do this for 24 48 hours
72 hours and then you're going to vote
anyway funny because we're transitioning
to a world which where it's basically
like tell me as much as possible in the
shortest time as possible has a
filibuster ever worked in the sense that
they were able to like push it over uh
until something uh
i'm sure it's worked otherwise they
wouldn't do it i guess right or or is it
just a political uh grandstanding where
like it's kind of like right now i mean
i'm sure it's more of that than the
other but
i'll call right now right now there's uh
i think six or seven different uh crypto
executives that are all uh testifying
right in front of politicians i promise
you 25 to 50 of the questions have
nothing to do with actually trying to
solve problems or get educated it's all
let me get the clip so i can go viral on
the internet and tell everyone that
that's exactly what it is like when they
brought i got five minutes let's go yeah
remember when they brought mark
zuckerberg in and the lady was like oh
what about your haircut no yeah that one
and then the what the other guy asked
you said what about uh about fence that
counts what did he say oh yeah yeah
could you please shut down physics
he's like i don't think you know what
that is but
she was like uh sir there are those are
fake instagram accounts yeah and he's
like well shut it off
[Laughter]
he's like all right
that's when people realize politicians
didn't really understand the internet